Peter's hit me up Dustin Poirier man
he's training right now I just got a
noun firm bro take your ass to bye I'm
thinking about it yeah I'm off that
weekend I'm gonna get Oh Europe right
after Isis would you go see what would
you go absolutely not
you wouldn't know why for free yeah if
we were doing shows I don't travel for
free brother right
no you taking away from that though to
see the [ __ ] night Jimmy dopes not
flying 37 hours to do by sitting front
row to watch that fight be at my house
just click watching Dustin do work I
used on the show while you were gone
yeah I saw the pepper put the picture -
was it cool yeah he's the best man yeah
he got me choked up did he yeah he got
me choked up on there talking about his
girl being with him from day one yeah
it's like damn you got a ride or die man
yeah dude he saw he's a unique comment
and he's actually not funny like you you
gotta get to know his personality but
acts as a goofy side too you know
no he's funny for sure he's an
interesting dude bro I asked him one
time I was like so you know what about
school he like what school like eighth
grade they said you and him went the
same school I just thought they stopped
in Louisiana like there's only
elementary and then after that doll now
you got this all figured out Louisiana
bro whatever dude you're built like that
last piece of bread bro that [ __ ] you
talk about the background in a lot of
gay circles you're known as that last
piece of bread because you and Dustin in
finish fifth grade yeah take your anger
out on me yeah not my fault your mom
[ __ ] up your curriculum there's 12
grades you idiot okay not fair five bro
bet the under dude if your schools
but I remember tenth grade Louisiana was
recipes that was our main class and to
graduate you'd learn magic oh dude I'm
thinking about going to the fight though
we'll see man are you really yeah
dude stay home but fancy go to Europe oh
you're on tour in Europe I'm heading to
Europe that following week so you're
gonna bounce so you go before then
bounce
yeah I'm just I'm nervous about being in
that audience like if people would like
attack us now here's the thing
Dustin brought up the the same point
he's like you know if I if I win I got
to get out of it it's not like that that
place is so modern Americanized so much
money there's none of that [ __ ] going on
there you really didn't have anything to
worry about have you heard of the Middle
East yeah there's a lot of good places
man nah don't want Isis scare you away
look I'm on to you Hooters okay you love
Hooters in [ __ ] the Middle East bro
[ __ ] with Hooters student in some
countries Hooters is like they it's the
American Embassy yeah that's called New
Orleans you you you and doesn't have
nothing to worry about I don't know man
it's such a tough fight for him though
brother oh yeah I'm rude I've never rode
so hard for anyone in my life after
you're done I give him how guys I Love
You Man and they walk around that is
such a tough fight yeah stop by if
daniel cormier was fighting you might be
worried for DC yeah that's up good Kabhi
vez but you know what you gotta fight it
that's the thing it's like if you don't
do the fight you don't know you you
don't you don't know you got to do the
fight what is the other option not doing
the fight now that's his job right
that's the thing if you know milk driver
you got a drive I drop that [ __ ]
nectar of the cow drop that white nectar
off but the thing is with Dustin if
you're gonna fight khabib do we have to
do it in Dubai can we not do it out here
I would have my chips against them I
would agree I would but they've been
stacked against him his whole life man I
would do it in a neutral ground I feel
like like maybe Haiti or something - in
England yeah do it in [ __ ] England
yeah I like England dude I asked us I'm
like dude you have any control and he's
like nah they're gonna tell me and I
just gotta go I said but then when you
beat on then you demand to fight in New
Orleans oh yeah
I would demand a fight I feel great
teacher my yard but yeah demand a fight
your front yard I got in Miami
dude I'm fightin but back in my mother's
womb bro on turf you feel me nobody's
beating you there dude did you say
hopefully not nobody's beating yet no
one is it's gonna be that dagestan Ian's
nightmare
oh yeah but I don't know man raw you've
seen him fight before huh yeah I watch
some of his face duties as his legs too
much I think you know so much or you
think you just want more more boxes I'm
just warmin right it's like you look
it's boxing dude if it were I think he
probably undeniably pound for pound the
best twister player in the entire
[ __ ] world would could be yeah pretty
good the guy has legs bro he's like a uh
you know he's like a tarantula man he's
like seventy legs Russian tarantula I
don't think they exist do now wouldn't
be surprised if at night his legs [ __ ]
each other make another good leg you
know I'm saying it just keeps
multiplying bro yes but his legs are
like on broccolini
get your life together touch me bro I'm
not touching